please welcome the incredible valerie
bertinelli
oh my goodness
well
i wasn't expecting that oh my gosh
oh my goodness
my eyelashes are going to come off
well drew that was that was so lovely
thank you so much for that wow
it is a true honor to honor you and your
life
um so i finished your book last night at
one o'clock in the morning oh honey and
um
i
i love your book
so much
i do feel
like um
i get to start this
uh
relating to a parallel life in some ways
um and having an understanding
of
what it's like to be on the cover of
people magazine at a young age
yeah and just the surrealism of that
and
you know you are america's sweetheart
and you're growing up and these eyes on
you and you're getting sexier and older
and
you know i what was that like
i i am recognizing now um at this late
stage in my life that um
that had a bigger impact on me than i
probably realized
um
that it shaped who i thought i needed to
be
and um it's it wasn't true i didn't need
to be
um
liked by everyone even though that's
what i was growing up to believe
um i believed that at a young age i
believed very um firmly because it was
shown to me that gaining weight made you
unlovable and i now know that that is a
lie and i'm trying to now just dig all
of that all the lies out of my body and
just accept who i am today and be
intentionally joyful
you know there
you got commented on oh my god you're
getting sexy wait this is america's
sweetheart wait she's this she's that
and i um
i think i finally learned to tune it out
and and
especially when i hit sort of a rock
bottom at 13 it gave me a liberation to
say i don't have to pretend to be
perfect anymore there was a liberation
in that and you were
this positive sunshiny sweetheart
and did you feel that way and you
married this rock star
where did you get to feel like they get
me or i get to live a different life i'm
not that person how did you navigate all
of that
i'm getting there now um back then i
didn't i mean i i remember being
so
angry
because and never being able to show it
because i nobody knew who i was and at a
certain point i stopped caring
um
so i went to therapy i said the first
thing i said to the therapist was i just
don't want to be this angry anymore so
we worked on that
so um that has helped actually a little
bit to then not take things so
personally when someone decides to tell
me that they don't like this or that
about me it's like well that's okay then
because i'm not for everybody but um
when it does resonate with people and i
can connect with people and i can um we
can talk about the same things the same
values it just feels you just feel
stronger i totally totally agree um
i would love to dive in um
to
the fact that
you know if food was something
that
was something you struggled with
through life how did
how did you take the thing
that could have been your downfall
through many years into your superpower
oh thank you um i truly believe that god
or the universe whatever you prefer the
higher power
um has a wonderful sense of humor
and um when we are here on this rock
trying to make our lives better for the
um
when we're not here
um
that unless we get to what we're here
for
we're not going to learn anything and i
needed to get through any kind of
stumbling blocks or whatever and for me
food
started as love food was the way my
mother shared all of her love with us
the way my grandmother my nonni i find
out that my great-grandmother was a chef
in shan remo so it's then she made
gelato so that she could make money to
come to america and start a brand new
life and get out of the poverty list so
i i think that i i spent too many years
thinking food was the enemy and it
wasn't because my introduction to food
was love
so i got back to that and that i've come
to the realization that it's not the way
i look
my body
is not what makes me lovable it's my
heart and and my mind and how i treat
you and am i leading with kindness am i
being respectful to another human being
am i treating them the way that i want
to be treated
i think god the universe
yeah that's making me work the work
until i get it that's exactly what i'm
talking about that's exactly what i'm
talking about and as a parent
who also um
did not stay in a marriage the
the way that you and
i know him as eddie you referred to him
as ed
you can report yeah he's yeah well i've
referred to a lot of a lot of things
i've called him a lot of things
the
time when you're
saying to him
um maybe next time right
both of us are crying maybe next time
we'll get it right
yep i believe that we are like any other
family in this situation and time
doesn't stop
as much as it ceases to matter and we
know the sand in the hour glass is
running low and we don't look we focus
our focus now is on the hope and people
talk about living in the moment nothing
puts you in the moment and makes you
appreciate what it means to live like
watching someone you love die
and it's all i think about as i sit here
this is what matters love
yep it begins with love and it ends with
love so why not fill all the in between
with love as well
and i i don't want to live with regrets
anymore i think regrets are are i've
never
not regretted regrets i think regrets
are helpful like mistakes and learn and
teach you how to not do the same thing
over again so all the regrets that i
have um
i've never regretted telling somebody
that i love them
never
[Music]
you